here they are everyone the new iPhone 15
and iPhone 15 Pro Models
the new iPhone 15 Pros have a new
titanium design action button and
improved cameras but the biggest news
from today's Apple event we're bringing
USBC to iPhone 15. yep I basically came
all the way to Apple's Cupertino
headquarters to see a tiny hole and to
see if anyone would well take my
lightning collection which is basically
trash
but seriously the switch from lightning
to USBC may be the biggest iPhone news
to impact you in years allow me to
answer all your important questions I
won't apologize for that pond number one
what's this port anyway there are four
new iPhone 15 models and they all have
USBC ports it's the same port found on
Android phones iPads and most Windows
and Mac laptops and pretty much every
other modern consumer Gadget so that
means you can charge all those things
with one type of cable it's goodbye to
Apple's favorite proprietary Port
introduced in 2012. our new connector is
called lightning this connector is a
modern connector for the next decade but
of course now apple is saying this USBC
Port is even better especially on the
pro models using a USB 3 cable with
iPhone 15 Pro enables incredibly fast
transfer speeds so it's much faster to
transfer your large Pro Raw photos or
prores videos to your Mac yes the iPhone
15 pro and pro mask can now get 20 times
faster transfer speeds than previous
iPhones if you have a special USB 3
cable another neat trick you can charge
airpods or the Apple watch directly from
an iPhone 15 model with the USBC
connector and when you buy an iPhone 15
you'll get a new cable but not just any
cable it's a higher quality rated cable
that should mean no more of this
grossness
number two why is Apple doing this well
to be clear Apple didn't want to remove
lightning but the European Union was
adamant it wanted a common charger
really you can blame this guy I'm Alex a
member of the European Parliament and
some may call you the lightning murderer
as you like if you like it call me soon
no problem this is the past
and this is the present yes he led the
EU legislation
2024 mobile phones tablets and other
receptacle AKA pork Apple wasn't happy
we have benefits for consumers benefits
for the environment faster when it comes
to charging faster when it comes to data
transfer so why should we continue to
use lightning cable the only advantages
for Apple to continue to sell
proprietary charging Solutions which
cost more for our consumers we were in
Cupertino two years ago trying to meet
with apple as legislators to explain
what we were doing they were not even
engaging brushing us off saying that
they will see when and if the
legislation will be approved they will
see how they will adopt adapt to it in
interview with me last year Apple's
senior vice president of worldwide
marketing red joswiak argued that this
would just create more E-Waste since
over a billion people would have to get
rid of their lightning cables
governments you don't get to do what
they're going to do and obviously we'll
have to comply we think the approach
would have been better environmentally
and better for our customers to to not
have a government be that prescriptive
which really does lead to our biggest
issue
these number three what do I do with my
old cables
maybe Tim Cook wants my collection he's
in there someplace
like there's no way I can get in there
if you're buying one of these new phones
these are all relics now essentially
trash now when Android phones went
through the micro USB to USBC transition
and laptops from USB a to USBC these
sorts of dongles became popular and now
apple is continuing its tradition of
selling a 29 dongle of course it's more
likely that you'll keep those old
lightning cords in a bag or in your
drawer Apple does say you can recycle
your old cords at its stores and there
are plenty of e-cycling options
but one thing is becoming increasingly
clear Apple doesn't like ports on its
phones at all rip headphone jack we're
taking the headphones an iPhone 7 and 7
plus to lightning it really comes down
to one word
Courage the courage to move on do
something new that betters all of us and
over the years the company has focused
more on its wireless charging mag safe
option and for an easy wireless
connection to Chargers and other
accessories iPhone 15 has magsafe which
means it's really only a matter of time
before I come to one of these Cupertino
events and see a totally portless iPhone
and say USB see you later
I'm not proud
yeah it's it's down there rip lightning
rip